[Music]
good morning my dear
so tehran is an espionage thriller about
a young mossad agent sent to tehran for
a special mission
it's the first time that you see on
screen a completely different humane
angle of the iranian-israeli conflict
it shows the messy gray area of life
there's no black and white
and i think that's truthful
from the first season
tamara bignan
infantry tehran the mission basically
failed
and second season we are two months
later
tamal and milad they are stuck hiding
from the mossad and from the zeppa
pharaohs has been chasing her for a long
time they are seemingly determined to
get out of iran but you know in this
show
plans don't work out
i can't leave yet a war against the
regime becomes really really personal
i know how to get to austin mohammadi
and i want to take him out oh
his son payment
season two deals a lot with the
hypocrisy and double standard
in tehran you have very wealthy people
connected to the regime
tamara is in a more dangerous position
she needs to get deep undercover near
the most important people in tehran and
the most dangerous people she has a lot
to lose
each person has their own story
you're not always sure exactly who's
antagonist and who's protagonist faraz
he's the most feared man in the iranian
intelligence because of his work his
wife was kidnapped and he was shot
so naheed is dealing with ptsd
and varus is a different man now sort of
a husband
he wants to be back where he was
playing close he's joining us this
season
she's what he would expect from glenn
close and much more mahjong is a very
high profile psychiatrist and deep cover
massage agent
i come as a therapist for nahid
that's one of those very conflicted
moments as a psychiatrist versus an
in our series we offer a new perspective
on tehran we really wanted to see people
in iran how do they live what do they
think
you really feel like you're deep in
another culture
it's not only about the action
there's so many layers she could trust
him yeah can he handle it it's high
stakes but there's a lot of emotion in
it the season is much more exciting
dangerous heartbreaking
it's really intense and fast-moving
and just great entertainment
it's so much fun
you